♪ ♪ (intro music) ♪ ♪
- [Announcer] Live from the Nestle Area.
Welcome to the finals of the 1987
jazz fit championships
Representing The Body Shop
from Hollywood, California
FLASH
And from the Skinny Shop in
Detroit, Michigan
LIGHTNING
- [Lightning] You son of
a bitch! - [Flash] Hey!
- [Lightning] You mother(beep)
you tried to (beep) family you (beep)!
- [Flash] Hey! Hey!
- [Flash] (laughs) - [Lightning]
I'll kill you motherfucker
you're done!
- [Flash] (laughs) - Let me at him!
- Let me at him
- [Flash] (laughing)
- [Announcer] (beep)
- Let met at him!
- [Lightning] Let me at him!
- [Flash] (laughs)
- [Female Judge] We Met
B boy Joseph in Atlanta
GA.
Hi Joseph
- 'Sup?
- [Female Judge] (laughs)
- [Jordan] All right?
Yeah? Start the music.
♪ (techno music playing)♪
- Has he started yet?
- Dear, God. Pretty sure this is it.
♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ (intense hip-hop) ♪
- Thank you
- Yeah, thank you.
- Yeah.
- I 'ain't done yet 'doe.
- Thank you, Joseph.
It's, it's, definitely a no for me
- It's a no. I'm sorry.
- No.
- All right.
Thank you, Joseph.
- Thank you
- [Female Judge] Yeah.
- 'Cuz, you-you know, I-I-I
ain't got no formal training
or nothing like that I
learned on the streets.
- [Jordan] Well, it was very apparent
as it turns out, Joseph.
So, thank you for coming.
- You know that my, uh my mom was on
drugs and my daddy in jail?
- It's not-not really relevant.
- [Female Judge] Yeah.
- Born in a coffee can under a bridge?
- [Peele] That's terrible, Joseph.
That's that's awful,
but it's not going to-
- [Joseph] My sister
- Shot my brother while
my cousin beat my uncle?
- Okay. - Now it's a lie.
- Okay. Its- It's a
little bit much Joseph,
thank you very much but
- [Joseph] Put myself through school
by renting my body out
as a heroin suit case.
- All right.
- Wow.
I see what's going on. Joseph please.
We-we do have other dancers here
today who are waiting
their turn very politely.
- [Peele] No, Joseph,
let her come on stage.
- [Peele] Let her come,
now. - [Female Judge] Hey
- [Peele] Now, Joseph!
- If I won this competition, I
could put a roof over my house.
'Cuz I got a house I ain't
got no roof for real 'doe?
- Joseph?
- Just one little thing though.
- Don't do it, Joseph.
- [Joseph] Really big,
it was a loud bridge.
- Don't finish that sent-
- I got hearing damage in this ear
- Joseph
- and also in this ear.
- Joseph.
- The bridge had have trucks go over it
- Joseph
- because the bridge
- keep it
- 15 ton
- Hold it
Put it in your mouth and get off my stage.
- Ra-ra-rated six.
- Joe.
- That's a big truck
- -seph.
- [Peele] Okay, Joseph please.
[Peele] And who is this?
- Oh, who is this right here?
This is my 12 year old
daughter who I raise all
[Joseph] by myself without
to help of anybody else
in the entire world,
she is my inspiration.
- [Peele] Joseph, It doesn't matter.
There's nothing you can do, or say,
that's going to make us
change our minds today.
- 'Dat right there. 'Dat right there.
'Dat's her daughter. She blind.
(cane clinks on stage) Come on.
- (gasps)
- (clears throat)
So I raise 'em both by myself
without nobody else's help.
- Come get your ticket to Vegas.
- (Hooting)
- Tremendous! - Can you
believe it? - Did You see that?
- I'm getting goosies over here.
- (laughs)
- I'm getting goosies. I, I am!
♪ ♪ (Electro-pop music) ♪ ♪
- Nooice!
Nooice!
- [Nooice] Nooice!
- Nooice!
- Excuse me. Excuse me. 'Scuse me.
Excuse me. 'Scuse me.
- 'Sup? 'Sup, punk?
- What '''chu doing?
- I'm just nooicein' your nooice.
- Don't. It's mostly about the dancers.
- Oh yeah.
- Besides this is, you know,
I'm kind of the guy that says nooice
- Nooice!
- What happened?
- Nothin' happened. I just
nooiced you becauseuh'
you standin' up yo'self and yo' place
in this dance circle.
- No. No. no nooice.
Okay? Nooice is my thing.
No more nooice from you.
'Scuse me.'Scuse me. 'Scuse me.
- Ohhh nooice!
(cheering)
Nooice,
(music fading)
(snapshot)
♪ ♪ (majestic music) ♪ ♪
Nooice,
Nooice
Nooice!
(thunder)
Nooice
- Nooice
- You?
Nooice?
- Nooice.
- (crying ) Nooice
(bus door creaking) -
[Both] (screaming) Nooice.
- Nooice
- Noice
(birds chirping)
(phone notifications)
♪ (radio) ♪
- Race war! It's a god damn race war.
(gun shots) (car alarms)
- Flash mob, flash mob canceled.
The flash mob is canceled.
- [Sylvia] And now we
have a special treat.
Hold on to your yamakas okay?
From east to west you
know they're the best.
Gettin' you in the zone
for your milestone.
Is that cute?
Please welcome Gefilte
Fresh and Dr. Dreidel
- Yeah.
What's up Temple Path Israel?
Is there a Daniel
Rosenbloom in the hizzay?
- Oh yezzir there he is!
Check him out!
- What's up old man
- All right
♪ (Jewish-techno fusion) ♪
- [Sylvia] When you see
black people at a bar Mitzvah
it's very exciting.
It's like a scary ride,
and the kids just love it.
- [Gefilte] Right now we are
the number one bar/bat Mitzvah
party motivators and all in Nassau county.
- [Dreidel] I mean you
got the bot mizzles.
- [Gefilte] Yeah.
- Boys to men, you
know, all of them comin'
through like a Vidal Chilla
with the recycled dress.
- [Gefilte] And I mean
the chutzpah in these guys
with their focaccia shtick
its a real Shonda of
what it's supposed to be
- [Dreidel] A Simca.
- [Gefilte] Yeah.
- It's supposed to be a Simca.
- Just really can't
put a price on the look
on your child's face. When
they see a black person
for the first time it's
(bang)
- [Crowd] Oh!
- Ugh, it's just magical. Really.
Is he getting back up or what?
- [Dreidel] We are not technically chosen.
- [Gefilte] We're chosen
by the chosen by the chosen
- [Dreidel] Which is kind
of better than being the,
just the chosen
- That's right. It's less responsibility.
- [David] Jews are like black people
but we were black people
before there were black people.
Um, although I guess that's not true
(bang)They were just
in a different part of, uh, the world,
Oh! Black people coming to get me! Help!
♪ (Jewish-techno fusion) ♪
(clapping)
- [Gefilte] Find it
spiritually intoxicating.
[Gefilte] Find it culturally fascinating.
And we find it monetarily exhilarating.
- When we say Sarah, you say Schwartzman,
Sarah
- [Crowd] Schwartzman
- Sarah
- Yeah. Oh yee. Woo!
- [Dreidel] I mean the fact
that we're willing to put
[Dreidel] forth the extra
time is what sets us apart.
- [Gefilte] I mean how
often is a 13 year old
gonna hear their own name?
- We learn that name. We rehearse it.
- [Gefilte] Go Daniel! Go
Daniel! Go Daniel! Go Daniel!
- Judaism could be a very somber religion.
- Yeah, that's right.
You know, something we
learned along the way
is that the word ghetto
means something very
different to these people.
- [Sylvia] To tell you
the truth. I was a little
[Sylvia] nervous about
the whole thing and no,
[Sylvia] not because they
were black, but because
you never really know
what those kind of people
are gonna do.
- [Dreidel] If we can
add some fun, some life,
some color to a Jewish person's life
when they're still young,
- [Gefilte] They might
not grow up and run away
[Gefilte] from black
people when they see 'em.
- [Dreidel] Um, maybe they won't
- [Gefilte] Or, Uh
- Fire people so willy
nilly. When they're older.
- [Gefilte] We provide a
service to these people.
- Yeah!
- We motivate parties.
- So that's what we do.
- That's what we do. We motivate parties.
♪ (House Music) ♪
- [Announcer] It's Friday Night!
[Announcer] Make some noise!
- [Crowd] (cheers)
♪ Put yo' motherfuckin' hands in the air ♪
♪ If you cool like a
pimp, put yo' hands up ♪
♪ 'Cuz you're an actual
♪ If you own a bunch of
women, put yo' hands up ♪
♪ If you gonna hit it all
night, put yo' hands up ♪
night, put yo' hands up. ♪
♪ If you maintain an
erection for 12 hours ♪
♪ put yo' hands up ♪
♪ Without the benefit of
Viagra, put yo' hands up ♪
♪ If you a real live
playa, put yo' hands up ♪
♪ If you abuse women's
trust, put yo' hands up ♪
♪ If you treat her like
objects, put yo' hands up ♪
♪If you a real live
gangster, put yo' hands up ♪
♪ If you kill other
people, put yo' hands up ♪
♪ If you the biggest boss
here, put yo' hands up ♪
♪ If you run an actual drug
ring, put yo' hands up ♪
♪ If you just realized that you're ♪
♪ full of shit, put yo' hands up ♪
- [Crowd] (cheering)
♪ (outro music) ♪